挑战永远给100个产品做广告, 今天做的是OPPO Find X9 Ultra, 今天给大家分享制作思路, 我的流程毫无保留地告诉大家, 先看今天
我們必須要準備好
這個計劃是很好的
我看你做的事
流程分为五步
一,分析产品,生成全系列图片, 用画布做
二,生成完了所有图片, 用图生视频
三,用AI做原厂营业, 商业上可以避免版权问题
四,用AI做培音
五,剪辑和做声音设计
今天我要教给大家一个非常关键的点
第一步就是要给你的产品做产品定位
这个是在生涂之前的,而且这一点非常重要
大家可以看到我刚开始做了一些概念头
大概就是OPPO手机的风格
我觉得还蛮好看的
但是有一个问题
这个手机的定价就是非常高
如果这个手机只是四五千的水平
那这个AI模特就是完美
但是这个价位
愿意买它的人更多的是在意产品的情绪价值
所以它更适合去做概念性的情绪性传递的广告
那么定了这个基调
给你的人物去写小传
以前广告实拍怎么拍
现在就怎么样去做
AI这个流程千万不要去变
你要构建的是一个让观众相信的世界
比如大家看到这个广告
知道这个人是干嘛的
至少是个公司里管事的高质量人群
这和产品人物画像是匹配的
它工作的环节你软住一些得了
当我们看到它的工作碎片
我们是非常相信
我们的潜意识会脑补这个故事
后面在转场的时候
我们看到它有家庭
有小孩
我们传达的这个情绪
手机再拿出来
这个产品就非常饱满了
这个技巧交给你以后
你也去试试吧
做出属于自己的AI相依广告